تجري مراكز مكافحة الأمراض الآن
جهودًا ضخمة لتتبع جهات الاتصال
لتنبيه الأشخاص الذين ذهبوا إلى
مؤتمر للرسوم المتحركة الشهر الماضي في مدينة نيويورك
حول الإصابات مع متغير omicron covid الجديد الذي
انضم إلي الآن هو بيتر
ماكجين الذي حضر هذا المؤتمر في
مانهاتن في نوفمبر مرة أخرى  وهو
أول شخص يتم تحديد هويته على
أنه حالة مؤكدة لمتغير omicron في
الولايات المتحدة بيتر ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لكونك معنا هذا الصباح
، لم نتحدث إلى أي شخص لديه
omicron ، لذا أخبرنا فقط بما فعله  أشعر
وكأنني شعرت وكأنني برد معتدل
لمدة يوم تقريبًا ، كان لدي إجهاد خفيف
وسيلان في الأنف والتهاب في الحلق وبعد
يوم اختفت هذه الأعراض ، لذا
لم تكن مجرد نزلة برد ، كيف
تم إخطارك بها
أو  نبهت إلى القلق بشأن
omicron ،
نعم أه قسم الصحة لدي أه
أجرى مقابلة أه كوفنت معي
في 29 تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) وبعد يومين
أعادوا الاتصال بي قائلين إنني
لم أطمح فقط  لكنني أول شخص في
مينيسوتا لديه المتغير ثم
ذهبنا من هناك مع تتبع جهات الاتصال
وأم تحاول إجراء ومحاولة
الحصول على أكبر قدر ممكن من المعلومات حول
المتغير الذي كنت أشعر به
وأعراضي وأشياءي  من هذا القبيل ، لذا فأنت تقول إن
حالة خفيفة من سيلان الأنف هل كنت ستخضع
للاختبار لو لم يكن هناك هذا
القلق المحيط بالاتفاقية
أه بصراحة لقد شعرت بصراحة أنني
ربما لم أكن لأخضع للاختبار
لمجرد مدى خفة الأعراض
التي أعانيها وأنا شديد جدًا  سعيد لأنني فعلت ذلك
وأنا سعيد لأنني قادر على التواجد هنا والتحدث
عن الأشخاص الذين لديهم أسئلة
ومخاوف بشأن البديل الجديد